so much natasha now back in june we were
joined by hideo kojima to announce death
stranding director's cut for playstation
5. tonight mr kojima has prepared an
in-depth video to give you a look at the
gameplay and many of the new features
missions and more that you'll encounter
when the game arrives on playstation 5
on september 24th so please sit back
relax and enjoy an extended look
prepared just for opening night live at
death stranding director's cut
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are now new items that allow for
easier and safe delivery
one of the new items is the evolve
stabilizers which features thrusters
that help reduce the impact of landing
when jumping from higher areas
the cargo catapult is a canon-like
device that can launch your cargo over
long distances
[Music]
enabling you to develop even more
creative ways to deliver your cargo
safely and more efficiently
you should have more faith in yourself
your trusted partner the buddy bog has
increased capabilities also
if you want to move around comfortably
while carrying more cargo you can rely
on bodybot to assist you
load up what you want to deliver and
leave the cargo carrying to your buddy
you can relax and think about what you
need for the next delivery
yeah like that
[Music]
the firing range has been set up in the
basement of the facilities
practicing how to handle your weapons
could level up your delivery skill set
you can also train and compete for the
highest score
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as you progress through the game
you'll also be able to unlock new
missions and weapons
the mazer gun is one of the new weapons
that will be introduced it has a few
different functions it can inflict
sustained stun damage to enemies
boss battles can now be revisited and
fought as many times as you like via
your private room
[Applause]
your scores will be shared in the
all-new online ranking system
allowing you to compete with players
from around the globe
eight new tracks have been added in the
music player
you can listen to the tracks in the
private room
it will help you and sam relax after
new action-packed delivery missions have
been added
okay
what truth will sam unfold in the
mysterious facility
[Music]
we've also added jump ramps enabling you
to jump over valleys and crevices with
these
you can even do tricks
[Music]
[Music]
there is a new race track you can time
attack with other sam players from all
around the world who are connected
online in the rankings
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
you